[Musique]
l'image indélébile
c'est le témoignage puissant et
bouleversant du photographe néerlandais
koen messing sur l'histoire de
l'après-guerre l'irlande des années 60
la violence et la barbarie en amérique
latine où l'apartheid en afrique du sud
khune singh capte les regards le
désespoir le drame de ceux qu'il appelle
les damnés de la terre
80 clichés en noir et blanc à la fois
magnifique et bouleversant
c'est vraiment les moyens des
traductions de l'horreur absolue quoi
c'est beau en même temps il ya une
poésie puis ces visages sont très graves
et encens l'atmosphère de la guerre quoi
bon je crois que c'est
c'est vraiment des images très parlante
ces femmes fouilles et c'est ces
militaires par tous et on est saisi par
l'horreur de la guerre quoi
l'horreur de la guerre au chili ou
betting assisté au coup d'état de
pinochet en 1973 autodafé dans les rues
fouilles arrestation il fut un des rares
photographes à entrer dans le stade où
des milliers de personnes furent
torturées clichés d'un quotidien hors
norme où un jeune soldat et un
prisonnier lutte pour une cigarette
koen v sync est mort en 2011 juste avant
son retour à santiago du chili pour une
rétrospective de son travail
c'est dans un entretien réalisé en 2010
qu'il évoque sont conflits intimes entre
la violence du réel et l'esthétisme de
ses photographies taille pour pemex ford
fait froid au pays nous soutiennent
[Musique]
ces drames là que nous on a connu qu'on
a vécu à certains moments à travers des
images avec des actualités à travers des
textes on en voit là des traductions
réel physique ont quelques uns étaient
et les regarde les situations des
positions le climat tout ça ça se
resserre 9 ce travail la cuvée singh est
un photographe méconnu en france
une injustice réparée avec cette
exposition du jeu de paume un regard
émouvant et saisissant à la fois sur
l'histoire contemporaine et ses
bouleversements à découvrir jusqu'au 12
mai au château de tours
[Musique]